there's no paparazzi here now which one
is this this is uh interns yes we're
just showing a section oh thanks friend
why do you hate friendship
it doesn't i don't have any
[Music]
hey conan o'brien here welcome to
another edition of behind the nonsense
where we try to get behind the scenes of
some of the uh well things we've done
on the conan show over the years
today we're going to uh be joined
by my assistant
my friend i think hey
okay no touching
uh sona obsession so now first of all
how are you feeling i know you're very
very pregnant with twins i feel fine
i don't i don't feel fine you don't feel
fine no i just i don't feel great then
why'd you say i feel fine i don't know
because i feel like i should but
what's tv you're supposed to kind of lie
a little bit okay well glad you feel so
terrific
the important thing sona is that we're
here to talk about our dynamic
and there are people that think
sometimes that
maybe we put a little english on the
ball
maybe some of what they're seeing on tv
is kind of a performance oh uh i do not
think that's the case at all
i think this remote we're about to show
demonstrates
pretty much exactly what our
relationship is okay this is a a time
when i tried to get to know the interns
yeah i started talking to them
and um
we had a happy accident i didn't know
what was going to happen when i was
talking to the interns just started
chatting with them one of them uh
reveals some information
uh i follow that trail where it leads
and it was a jackpot jackpot all the way
let's take a look then we'll discuss
evan yes sir you know i remember evan
type
not just the name tag
although that's helping
evan's enthusiasm feeds me
i also got your lunch
today you got my lunch today yeah i
didn't eat lunch today
how did you get my lunch if i didn't eat
lunch today they told me to go get uh
the boss man's lunch who told you to get
conan's lunch
give me a name nick nick
who's nick what's nick what's a nick
evan
was told today to go get conan's lunch
absolutely i did that
but conan didn't eat lunch
conan didn't even order lunch i spoke
with soda
soda
we went into a little bit of a snafu
here
evan said hey i got your lunch today i
said that's not possible i didn't order
lunch today sometimes in order to get
things done quickly
for me i might use your name to like
light a fire under what else are you
doing for yourself where you use my name
i'd rather not say this please say it i
uh once went to a bar and drank too much
and couldn't drive home so i sent
interns the next day this was a long
time ago to pick the car up and i may
have said that i needed them to pick
your car
she just walked away
she walked away
there's people out there that think
conan o'brien had too much to drink and
couldn't get his car
what rumors have you heard about me
i'm really glad we saw that did you know
when i called you why you were being
called i don't think you knew no i
didn't i thought you were just shooting
a remote with the interns yeah yeah so
then i confront you and i'm gonna give
you uh
major credit here one of your strengths
and probably your weakness is that you
always tell the truth yes you always
tell the truth so i asked you and you
you can see on camera you go oh boy all
right well here's the truth yeah and
then you tell me
that um half the valets in town think
i'm an alcoholic
and that i
drive a jetta an old jetta you don't
have to say it like with such disdain no
i love hey volkswagen you guys are
killing it and the jet is a fine machine
in its day
but oh my god you did not take good care
of that car but that's not the point
let's not go down that cul-de-sac i love
that this remote
reveals something about you which is you
love to complain about me but if you can
get a perk
in your own life
or a little bit ahead using the conan
magic you do it
did you or did you not we went to a
restaurant once you met me at a
restaurant and you brought your dog to
the restaurant
and
i was like i don't think you can have a
dog in the restaurant and you're holding
your dog and you said well i made the
reservation under your name and they
know i'm with you and that's why i knew
i could bring my dog in you used me
and then i'm the guy who brought the dog
when i didn't bring the dog i never
bring a dog to the restaurant what am i
french don't you think i've earned it a
little bit though
earned what earned using your fame for
my benefit
come on
don't you think i've earned it a little
whoa come on
you can't just say that's not a debating
style come on am i a defense i put up
with a lot oh please a lot yes yeah a
wall of talent with red hair okay no i
mean i put up with a lot and i think
that sometimes if i want to bring my dog
to a restaurant what are you doing
to distract you it stopped you i did
and then i went stupid uh you're a
criminal uh-huh you're a criminal uh who
uh takes advantage of me
um and you were caught in the act right
here uh you ordered lunch and you said
yeah conan needs his lunch right now and
then you probably ordered something you
like i did what did you order that day
do you remember no how do i remember
what i ordered that day you shot an
intern remote i have no idea probably a
sandwich you should does it matter you
should keep better records
records of my lunches yes you should
keep better right is that even no that's
silly okay you're right what did you
have for lunch that day i didn't get
lunch that day would he you probably ate
something that you already had in the
office no i didn't order lunch that day
and i think a lot of times i did without
lunch i wanted to suffer during the day
so my audience could feel joy at night
anyway
so irish sometimes please what does that
even mean i don't know that's a slander
it is i shouldn't have said that but
there is something that comes from who
you are and where you come from that
makes you very odd
that's all i'm saying
odd in what way uh odd in what you just
said how you make yourself suffer so
that your audience can have joy yes who
says that that's weird true artists
say that don't say true artists why not
i think what i do is art
do you disagree
yes
i'm here with interns finding out who
took my lunch
[Laughter]
who's to say
that what rafael or jotto did
is finer than what i did
oh well anyway there you have it and
another glimpse behind the nonsense sona
we love you you know that right i love
you too i'll have that part cut out
don't touch me okay
[Music]
have the babies kicking right now
they're probably they are they're moving
i saw that they're like struggling to
get out and say conan's right conan's
right
they're not gonna say that will they be
conan fans these two fellows you know
what yeah i think they will good